so my name is Kara Tanaka I'm going to
talk about numpy and
learn some cool tricks and has a lot
more of an easy time with computation in
Python has everyone cloned the github
repository if you haven't this is the
link it has the notebooks that I'm going
to be using for this tutorial so if you
want just go ahead clone it and then you
can follow along with the rest of the
tutorial
everyone can see that is just fine right
if anyone needs me to zoom it further
please let me know otherwise I'll go
ahead yeah okay more all good
okay has everyone got the notebook or
should I wait for a couple more minutes
before everyone's ready all good so to
start off with let me give you a little
a very short introduction to numpy numpy
or numerical python is pythons premier
scientific mathematical and computation
library it's called a lot of vector I
got a lot of highly optimized functions
in it to do you know some hardcore math
which makes it a lot easier if you're
using code that rise on efficient
performance it's a lot of number
crunching and if you need things fast
then numpy is the best way to do that as
we know traditionally python is a fairly
slow language and it may not be useful
for all your use cases because sometimes
you need speed and when you need speed
numpy is a really good way to get it so
having said that I'm going to dive right
into the notebooks and as we go through
the notebook I'll talk about different
parts of numpy and hopefully you guys
can understand where you can use numpy
in the work that you do and if anyone
has any questions during the tutorials
please feel free to raise your hand stop
me and I'm happy to answer whatever
questions you have so to start off with
first thing we do is we have to import
numpy so that's what I've started off
with my in my notebook now the the core
fundamental foundational data structure
in um pi is the adit and I'm just gonna
start off with some examples how you can
create an umpire array there are many
different ways to do it
one is you using the syntax NP dot array
you pass in a list of whatever elements
you want here I've passed in a list of
two four and six and then a now becomes
an umpire
and there you go that's it you can also
create an umpire array using the
function ones in this case what you pass
into it is a tuple that represents the
shape of the output array that you want
to create filling all the elements with
one so here if I want an array that has
two rows and three columns and all
elements in it to be one I can use this
function in P dot once pass in two comma
three to it and it gives me an array of
all ones just like this here it takes
the default as the data type default as
float which is why you see one point and
one point all over I can also pass in
the data type that I want here using the
D type parameter and here it creates an
umpire area of ones where the data type
is an integer I can do the same thing
with n P dot zeros function again here I
passed in the shape as 3 comma 2 so I
want three rows and two columns in my
output array all L all elements should
be 0 and that's how I get it numpy has a
function arranged which is similar to
pythons range function except this is
not a generator it actually creates a
list of elements from the start and stop
point of your range
so here I've the function I've written
is NP dot a range of 10 so I haven't
passed in a start stop and step I've
just said 10 so by default it assumes
the start to be 0 it takes 10 as the end
and it creates a range a list with the
range 0 to 9 that's what you get over
here so now I have an umpire array of
elements 0 to 9 2 more cool functions
are tile and repeat what tile does is it
takes the first argument in this case
it's 2 and it tiles it together in the
shape fast as the second argument in
this case it's 5 comma 3 so that means
this function will take the element 2
and and replicated so that it reaches
the shape five comma three so in this
case you now have an array with fire
rows and three columns each of the
element 2
what I can also do here is instead of
two which is just an integer I can pass
in another numpy array I can pass in a
list so let's try passing in what I
created before so if i taked I'll pass
in NP rot a range of 10 and say the
shape output shape I want is 5 comma 3
this is what it does as you can see here
along the columns it's repeated the
sequence 0 to 9 three times because
that's the number of columns I specified
in the second argument of the tile
function it's taken the list and
replicated it five times on the rows
which is why we have 5 rows of this
sequence of 30 numbers so that's what
the tile function does repeat is similar
except it takes whatever you pass in as
the first argument and simply repeats it
linearly specified by the the number of
times specified by the second argument
so in this case it takes the list 1
comma 2 and just repeats the list
linearly 5 times so here takes 1 it
takes each element of the list and
repeats it the number of times specified
by the second argument so here I pass in
the list 1 comma 2 and unlike tile it
doesn't take the entire list and repeat
it it takes each element and repeats it
based on what you specify in the second
argument so which is why we have 1 5
times followed by 2 5 times so that's
difference between tile and repeat now
this function linspace what you can do
with this is specify a start to the
range you want an end to the range you
want and the number of elements you want
within that range so with this function
what I'm doing is I'm specifying that I
want my
sequence to start with one I wanted to
end with five and I want ten equidistant
points within that range so it
calculates what Delta should be added to
each number to create an equidistant set
of numbers between one and ten
oh sorry one in five and ten of in ten
such numbers is everyone good so far
does anyone have any questions
okay now the NP dot matrix function can
be used to create a matrix instead of
creating with the different syntax then
you would have used if you use the
numpad or array function so here I
personally don't like this method of
creating an array because I would rather
just use NP dot array and pass in a two
dimensional list to it I feel it's more
intuitive it's more it's more likely to
be what you use through your general
programming i I've never you I've used
numpy for a long time and I've pretty
much never used the matrix function so
to me it's a pretty useless function but
I just thought I'd put it in here anyway
so that everyone knows that this is an
option that exists not sure why you take
that option but it exists so this is the
way you would specify that so along the
rows you have one and two and and on the
next row you have three and four and you
create a matrix that way if anyone finds
a compelling use case to do this please
tell me
yeah but could also just do is num-num
five from txt or something right yeah
that's I mean that's what yeah that's
obviously a useful use case but I meant
if you were like right in court where
you weren't doing it from a text file
then I wouldn't use this but yeah I have
to agree that does work you can also
create a structured array in numpy so in
this case here I have I want okay so
here I have a structured array where i
have labels and i have probabilities as
the two data types that i want to store
in my array so i've called the two
labels that i have a and b and the two
what i've called as probabilities which
are float values as 0.8 and 0.2 now the
first part is similar to the numpy dot
array syntax except here you're passing
data types of different categories and
in the d type is where you specify the
labels that you want each of these to
represent so in this case the first
value of the tuple this tuple the first
value is a label which is why i specify
that over here and it means it's a
string or character a character and then
the second value of the tuple which is
0.8 i've defined as probability or PR OB
and have specified the type as a float
now when i want to extract elements from
my array i can extract it extract it
through the label that I've given so
here I can say X of label and it gives
me a and B as the two type as the two
labels that I have in this structure
array and if I do X of probe it gives me
zero point eight and zero point two
because these are all the elements in my
numpy array labeled as probability so if
you have a larger set of data
and you want to get all the values that
you've defined by a particular label you
can index the array pass in that label
and then retrieve everything that is of
that particular label so that's how you
can achieve the structured array
functionality in numpy now that was the
basic stuff how to create an ad is some
of the basic things you can do with
numpy arrays now to get to some of the
cool parts of numpy and the coolest by
far and the most powerful part of numpy
is its broadcasting ability and that is
really what makes numpy very easy to use
it makes it efficient to use and it just
overall improves the programming
experience so here if I have two arrays
a and B each with three elements in it
and I wanted to do any operation on the
two of them together so for example
let's say I wanted to add these two
arrays together now if I was doing this
in for example C I would take the two
areas I would write a for loop out I
trade from 0 to 2 add each element
together store it in an output array
which is fine that's cool C plus C is
fast so we can do that in Python loops
are not your friend loops make things
really slow and you want to avoid loops
as much as possible so taking these two
arrays looping over it in a case of
three elements fine doesn't make a big
deal but if this was three thousand
elements you would not want to be
looping over to lists to add them
together with numpy you have the ability
to add these two lists together and
internally what it does it broadcast
this operation across all the elements
of the list so now the addition operator
is broadcasted to the first value in
each of the MIT arrays that I have to
the second and to the third to add all
of them together and what we see is one
operation so let me go ahead and define
this now if I want to add these two
together in one operation I'm able to
add element by element the two arrays
that I've just created
without this broadcasting ability if the
user to Python lists that I wanted to
add you'd have to iterate over each of
the lists and add them together and
store it in a third output area now
what's really cool is in the next case I
take the array a which has three
elements in it and I on the other side
of the plus I have a one it's not an
array but I want to add one to each
element of my numpy array what
broadcasting does here is it takes the
element takes the integer one it treats
it as if it was an array of three ones
because it sees that on the left-hand
side of the operator the dimension of
the array is of length three so it
broadcasts the one makes it an
internally makes it an array of three
and then does an element by element
addition of the two so in this case I
take the array a add one to it and each
element is incremented by one and that's
possible because of broadcasting and the
same way I can do it for all of these
operators for a minus nine subtract nine
from each of these elements and the same
if I multiplied by ten it multiplies
each of the elements in my array by ten
now with broadcasting there are
particular rules that you need to be
aware of to identify whether something
will follow broadcasting or whether it
won't and for that it's pretty simple
rule you look at each dimension of your
numpy array and for two areas to be to
be to facilitate broadcasting at each
dimension they should either be equal or
one of the dimensions should be one so
for example in the case over here
both of these arrays have the same exact
dimension so broadcasting would work in
the case over here you have a and one
one is treated as a dimension of length
one and a has dimension of length three
in which case it still follows the rules
of broadcasting because one of the two
is one so that's what you always need to
be aware of either that dimension should
be equal or
one of the well or one of the areas
should the dimension should be one so in
the case of this these two areas over
here if I want to add them then I know
that the dimension of my first array is
20 by 5 the dimension of my second array
is 20 by one so now I want to check
whether these two can be brought where
the broadcasting will take place in this
case or not so I start from the right
and I look at the second dimension and
in the array a it's the value is five in
the array B the value is 1 so that
checks out because one of them is 1 now
I go to the left and I see it's 20 the
first dimension of a the second first
dimension of B is also 20 again it
checks out because both are equal now in
this case I know the broadcasting can
take place which is why when I add it
it's all good the number numpy arrays
get added so now let me ask you will
these two numpy arrays will it work if I
add them two together can they be
broadcasted is anyone think they can't
be okay so everyone thinks they can be
okay let's check are you sure no one
wants to change their mind okay cool
and yeah they can be added together and
that's because that each dimension
the dimensions are either equal or one
of them was one how about this show of
hands for yes they can be door casting
will take place okay anyone for no okay
you think they won't be broadcasted okay
this one and yeah they can be
broadcasted okay and now for the next
one does anyone think they can't be
broadcasted this is the one that you
said you don't
yeah does anyone think they will be
broadcasted these two arias anyone still
not sure yes no or Not sure okay cool
let's try it out then and no they
couldn't be and that's because when you
look at these two areas over here the
first one is dimensions are nine one and
two and the second one the dimensions
are one nine and eight so when you look
start from the right side you see the
large dimension of a is 2 and the last
dimension of B is 8 and the rules of
broadcasting say that the dimension
should either be equal or one of them
should be one so this violates that
because they're neither equal and 1
neither of them is 1 which is why they
can't be broadcast in all of the
previous cases the dimension was either
equal or one of them was 1 which is why
it worked
now another really cool feature with
numpy is the ability to index into areas
in many different ways so again starting
with just in random array an area of 0
24 the colon operator is used as the
indexing operator so when I index into
an array like this what I'm telling it
is on the rows I'm just passing in a
colon which means I want everything
there's no start defined and there's no
stop defined so ideally in the colon the
syntax is on the left hand side of the
colon you have the start on the right
hand side of the colon you have the stop
if neither is specified it defaults to
just zero to end which is why on the
rows now everything is going to be
returned to me and in P dot new axis is
used to create a new axis if you look at
the array a there's only one it's a one
dimensional array right so if you were
to
if you were to check out the shape of a
is just 25 comma nothing because it's
one dimension now when I use this syntax
to index into the array and I pass in :
comma n P dot new axis what I'm saying
is take the array a give me all the rows
and add a new dimension to it after that
so now it takes this array and it
creates an artificial second dimension
so now the shape of this array becomes
25 comma 1 because the new axis has been
inserted into that array through the NP
dot new axis function here I'm not
storing it in a another variable which
is why in the subsequent examples it
won't retain the shape 25 comma 1 but
it's a way that you could you could use
this to reshape an area you could use
this to you know just add a new axis for
whatever you're doing of in some cases
for example if you use if you're using
carers for example and you pass in any
input data set to it sometimes it
requires you to have the last dimension
as one in which case you could just use
NP dot new axis pass in the array and
then your downstream computation would
be fine sorry no so when I do NP dot a
range of 25 it returns an array of
length 25 right so it's a one
dimensional array so here when I print
the shape of a it's 25 comma nothing
right because there's only one dimension
there's only it's a one dimensional
error it's a linear thing but now when I
pass in the second in the second line on
line 31 when I say NP dot new axis I'm
taking this 1 dimensional array of
length 25 and making it a two
dimensional array of 25 rows and 1
column which is why if you print this
it's 25 rows and each row has one
element right so now it's essentially a
two-dimensional array that second
dimension is introduced through the NP
dot new axis function in the operator
sorry in the indexing operator in the
square brackets yeah so now here I've
created a array of numbers from 0 to 24
and I've reshaped it to the shape 5
comma 5 comma 1 so it has five rows five
columns and each element has its own
artificial third dimension to it
so if you look at shape it is 5 comma 5
comma 1 which is what we specified no
surprises there
now another neat indexing operator is
the ellipsis which is which are these
three dots you see over here so now to
this in this line what I've done is I've
said I want from the array a which is
now three dimensional five comma 5 comma
1 give me the first row and everything
after that that's what this ellipsis
does it says everything that is left
from all the other dimensions should be
returned to me and that's what the
ellipsis is so here if you look at the
output you get the first row and you get
5 6 7 8 9 retained in the square
brackets because the next axis is 5
comma 1 and on the next line over here
it's the same thing so you can see that
the three dots the ellipsis function
translates to the colon operator in all
remaining dimensions so if I had my
array shape as 5 comma 5 comma 5 comma 5
comma 5 for however long I wanted and I
said I want the first row of this and I
don't want to specify that I want
everything from all the other dimensions
I can just do a of 1 comma dot dot dot
and that would translate to a of one
comma colon comma colon comma colon
comma colon for however long I've
specified my dimensions to be so it's an
easier way to access an index through
your entire numpy array now as we see
from this array a there is clearly one
dimension that is very unnecessary which
is the last one in this case right here
is not really serving a purpose for us
and many times when you're getting
inputs coming from different functions
or different processes you may receive
data that is shaped similarly and for
your downstream processes you may not
require having the data shape like this
with the third dimension or an nth
dimension with just one element in it
and there may be many cases where you
have many dimensions that are just one
for example in one of the broadcasting
examples that I put up you have this
array which is nine comma 1 comma 1 now
if I just want to treat that as an
linear array of nine elements because
the other two dimensions for me aren't
really serving a purpose I can use the
squeeze function which essentially
returns a new array to me with all
dimensions that were just one removed so
in this case now anyone want to guess
what the shape of a is going to be oh by
the way was 5 comma 5 comma 1 so now
after running the squeeze function any
guesses what the resulting shape of a is
going to be I have a cookie for anyone
who answers I brought one from outside
yeah okay yeah okay so who gets the
cookie now you guys want to share go for
it otherwise there are more questions
later and we can give the cookie to
someone who answers that and he's got
chocolates as well so now this is the
new value of s so that you want the
cookie go free
no no I brought this to give someone who
answers a question yeah
so here if I want for some odd reason
after I do all of this to get my array
back to being five comma five and
removing that dimension if I want to for
some reason bring that dimension back
then I can do this and do and index my
first and second dimension using the
colon so I'm saying I want everything
from the first and second dimension and
for some reason I now want this third
dimension again so I use the NP dot new
axis and we're back to the original
array another thing you can do while
indexing is you can pass in lists to the
row and column instead of just a range
through the colon operator instead of
seeing a start and end you can pass in
discrete values of which rows and which
columns you want to return from your
array so in this case just take a minute
and in the array that you see above
right here if this is what I pass to it
you know this would have been a good
question to give her a cookie for anyway
no hurries anyone want to take a guess
as to what the output of this line here
would be if I'm indexing my array with
oops
yeah if this is how I index my array the
first list is being passed as the row
index the second list is the column
index er what would the output be yeah
okay so the five items of the diagonal
is anyone think that that's wrong does
anyone think that you'd see something
else or does everyone agree with him
yeah okay it gives back the original
array okay so we have two guesses one is
the original one is the diagonal anyone
else
yeah
okay so you got three different answers
and whoever gets read gets a chocolate
from him and what we get is in fact the
diagonal and that's because it think of
it this way so now I fashioned a list
over here to the rows and a list of the
column and what it does is it takes row
0 column 0 Row 1 column 1 Row 2 column 2
Row 3 column 3 Row 4 and column 4 and
that would result in getting the exact
elements along the diagonal of the array
sorry oh yeah there are much cleaner
ways to access there this is not how you
want to be accessing the diagonal at all
I will come to the much much much better
ways to do it this is just an example of
how you can possibly index into a
non-fire yeah
I'm sorry I didn't fully understand what
what output are you saying you want to
see
oh okay so you want to basically reap so
the output should be the original array
but the method I used to get it should
be similar to this right like passing
into things okay okay we can try that
[Music]
cool so what we can try it so what do
you take what do you think you it should
be well you lost me after the 17th
bracket also a and then okay : and then
what do I do
again open to colon comma colon right
yeah you want to try this brackets after
this within it okay so we can try this
and if you dig deeper into this so it's
saying for the array a I want all the
rows because that's what the colon is
saying and I want all the columns so
that's currently what we've got and do
you want to try this or do you think
that it's missing something and do you
want to add something more to it and
then try it yeah okay we can try it if
you're not sure and yeah it works that's
how you would get all the elements :
because colon is saying everything in
the row and the second colon is saying
everything in the column so that is
exactly how you would get the entire
area again yeah and if you were to just
do the first colon as well it would work
and yeah so the indexing in this case it
refers it's called slicing so now when I
take the array a and I say a of zero : -
what's being returned to me is a slice
out of array a and that slice is
determined by what I pass inside the
square brackets in this case I'm saying
0 : 2 now since I haven't specified a
comma and anything after that it
automatically treats it as me specifying
0 comma 2 along the rows because that's
the first dimension and I'm not passed
in anything else so it reads 0 comma 2
to be along the rows so a of 0 comma 2
is essentially going to give me Rho 0
and Rho 1 out of my array a so we can
see that here so X is the first two rows
of the array a and now it's cool about
the slicing operator is it doesn't
return a new array it returns
essentially a reference to that slice of
the array so now if I were to take this
new array X or not new array this new
array X and change the first element of
it 200 so here X of 0 0 is now hundred
and let's print X so now you can see in
the array X the first element has
changed now what do you think will
happen to a how many say a changed and
how many say a hasn't changed okay let's
let's see what happens
a changes as well and that's because
like I said the slice operator in this
case the colon is acting as the slicing
function the slice that's returned to X
is merely a reference to that section of
the original array so if I go ahead and
start modifying X I'm actually just
modifying a reference it's actually just
a reference to a
so whatever modifications I make to X
are going to be reflected back onto a
which is why when I change the value of
x zero comma zero to hundred it's
actually a that's getting changed as
well because X is just a reference to a
so that's why a gets changed okay yeah
so there's the dot copy function which
returns a coffee and then you're good
and I've actually detailed that part
later because I faced quite a lot of
trouble with some code because I forgot
that you need to do this dot copy and I
will tell you about that when we come to
it okay yeah I have a bunch of questions
now I don't know why I gave away the
cookie so early yeah okay so anyone want
to guess what are the output of this B I
mean you can obviously try it out but
without trying it out anyone want to
guess what the output of this would be
or just talk through what you think the
orbital be and why you think it will be
that
oh yeah sure whoops
yeah okay
anyone else with any different answer
yeah okay yeah so that yeah that's what
you said right yeah okay so this yeah
same thing
any anyone else okay should we try it
out and in fact that is correct you get
so the colon colon 2 operator is saying
start from zero end with the end and
give me every second one so the third or
the value after the second colon
represents the skip so going from zero
to the end skipping two items at a time
giving all the rows and on the columns
I've passed in explicitly a list so I'm
saying I want only the first third and
fourth column so it takes every other
row and gives me the first third and
fourth column from that row which is why
I get the resulting array that we see
here just to like go into a little more
detail about this colon colon I could
have it essentially boils down to this
this colon colon 2 & 0 colon 5 colon 2
are the exact same thing and that's how
you can use the colon operator without
specifying exact ranges
now if you wanted to make things
slightly easier and do things in a
slightly faster more efficient way if
you knew that there was a particular way
that you wanted to index through your
array and now this could be for some you
know if you're using certain complex
mathematical functions and you need to
and if you have large matrices and then
you need to extract elements in certain
ways you can use the numpy IX underscore
function and what that does is it takes
the first argument you pass to it which
is in this case zero two it looks at the
first value in that which is zero and
pairs it with everything you see in the
second argument in this case that would
mean zero zero zero two zero three then
it takes the second value in the first
argument which is to pair it with
everything in the second so that gives
you two zero two two and two three and
returns that so now when you take this
is essentially a slice into or
essentially the what you would need to
pass in to the to the square brackets to
return the elements at zero zero zero
two zero three two zero two two and two
three and then when you take the output
of this and pass it to matrix a you get
those exact elements you'll get this is
zero zero this is 0-2 this is 0-3 this
is two zero two two and two three so
what this is doing is along the rows you
have this added zero comma two along the
columns you have this array zero two
three
it combines the two together in this
sort of cross-product manner and then
you're able to extract those elements
directly from your array this helps if
you have much larger arrays and much
larger sequences and then you can index
it using this numpy dot IX function so
now I have an exercise for everyone
to do and it'll be based on the two
things we just learned which is
broadcasting and indexing and this is
what you have to do you have to add the
two arrays together and then access the
first and last element of every
alternate row and just know someone tell
me what what I should type in and then
we'll see if the output is what it
should be
whenever anyone is ready just you know
raise your hand and then I can type in
what you say and we'll check if it works
or not
anyone ready
yeah
yeah that works
yeah that works anyone else want to give
it a shot yeah yeah plus B yeah yeah so
this is a like perfect example of how
you could use in P dot new axis I mean
or you could also use reshape but all of
these things do the same thing and this
the purpose of this was to show you that
there are so many different options of
how you can achieve all of this through
numpy and whichever one works most
convenient for you go for it and you can
unlock all of this power that numpy has
this in did anyone have any trouble with
this does anyone want anyone to explain
does anyone want any of these to explain
how they came up with this Oh
is everything all good yeah I'm gonna
assume everything is all good now just
to drive the point home that numpy
arrays are passed by reference about the
next next bit of code ready and and
that's because so let me tell you this
one time I was working on this program
at code I have at work I had to write
code to generate a function that would
able that was able to give me Hilbert
index values of coordinates I was
mapping a large numeric space into 2d
Hilbert coordinates and I started it was
taking me a while for some reason to get
this code working and I kept wondering
I'm like you know it I've copied this
off the Internet
I've just switched my lists to numpy
areas there is no reason for this thing
ought to be working and that's when I
realized I started debugging it and then
every time I passed my array into a
function and I looked at the array I'd
get the result but then my original
array would change and I'd be like wait
a minute why is this happening I don't
want my original array to change I'm not
doing anything to it I'm just passing it
to the function why am I seeing these
weird things then I went into that
function and looked at it it was
changing the incoming array and then
returning something that's completely
different and the reason it didn't
matter before is because I was passing
in a list and the reason
matter now is because I was passing in
an umpire array and he was passed by
reference which is why I was seeing all
of these insidious things on the other
side without realizing that on the
internal side its modifying my array and
I wasn't and I wasn't cognizant of the
fact that I should be passing in copies
of my array and odd references because
the first line of the function inside my
array was an indexing operator in which
cases start returning slices and
references and then everything just
propagated to the original array that I
was using on the outside so now if you
take this array a and I create I I now
to do B equal to a and then I check
whether B and a are the same thing it's
true and then using number you can check
whether they are actually physically the
same thing or not by looking at whether
they share memory and they do share
memory so when you pass in and when you
use the equal to operator to create and
you or do something like B equal to a it
is literally a reference you're passing
the same memory is being used for both
of these arrays which is why now if I do
a f1 as 100 it changes and B as well
because it's the same thing but then if
I do this I say a equal to B dot copy it
returns the values of B to a and creates
a new array so then now when I do this
and I see the second value of a is
changed to 9 9 9 9 and then I look at
what B is B doesn't change so in some
cases you may want this pass by
reference functionality in some cases
you may not yeah
now so I I had passed in numpy added to
it and then let's call that parameter X
now in the new function it was taking it
was directly indexing into X so for
example X of 1 and modifying that value
so when I'm probably ridden because in
the code that it was using it was just a
list in which case it didn't matter at
all so it's not something that the
author of the code is aware of but when
I switched it to a numpy array it was
immediately noticeable to me that it was
an incorrect implementation and then you
should not be directly modifying that
values no it was a completely non numpy
related function that I was using I was
just passing a numpy function number
array into it which is why I was seeing
this behavior and in the use case that
the author was working on that was not
of you know any value to him which is
why this wasn't taken care of but in
some cases you may also come across
similar functions where it wasn't
intended to be used with number arrays
but you want the same functionality and
then you need to be careful that you're
what you're making sure that values or
copies are passed instead of references
when you when you need them another way
to achieve the same functionality as B
dot copy is simply returning a slice of
B and that slice being the entire array
so B of colon then it basically says a
is equal to everything in B and then you
can do the same thing set one value of a
as 999 and whoops
yeah okay
right because be sorry my bad so copy
returns a copy of the array so it's not
a reference so when you make changes to
the original copy is not affected but
when you do the : then you're returning
a slice and slices are passed by
reference which is why when I modify an
element in a the slice of the reference
which is B is also modified as well so
whenever you want to ensure whenever you
want to enforce pass by value behavior
in Nampa use dot copy
yeah so using you have a Python list you
create an umpire a div using that list
and then you change the original array
then in that case that those changes are
not propagated to numpy because you've
created a new number array with the list
passed into it right so for example
think of NP dot areas like a constructor
you pass in values to it it takes those
values creates a numpy array and returns
to you a new number array right no it's
not pointing back it's it's creating a
new array creating a new piece of memory
returning that to you it's just taking
the values from the list you've got but
it's not actually in some way you know
pointing to that same original list and
then those changes will not be seen
further so this is an example using
functions so if I have this function
which takes in an array then uses the
star equal to operator to multiply each
element by two and return the array back
so here if I pass in an umpire array to
it so the output Y that's all good
that's 20 but if you see the input that
you passed in X that also changes and
that's because inside the function I've
used the star equal to operator and the
star equal to doesn't in place
multiplication so the actual reference
that was passed in is multiplied in
place which is why you see that
propagating on the outside and this is
not how you would want to write
your function but this is just an
example of what could happen if a
function is written this way because of
you know these properties of numpy now
the same thing if you would write it in
a better way
and you wrote your function like this
where you weren't using the in-place
multiplication operator you would still
see the same result from Y now the value
of y is 20 which is why you now see 40 X
remains 20 because array equal to array
star to the array star 2 is returning a
new array which is being returned to you
so the original is not being multiplied
it is not being multiplied by 2 again
because it's not an in-place operation
that's taking place the same thing
doesn't happen when you use an integer
this is for non PI RS in this case you
would see the same thing
yeah so in this case when I passed funk
when I passed my editor funk one
exchanged as well in this case when I
pass in an integer the integer does not
get modified even though I'm using the
same in-place multiplication operator so
that happens with the numpy array
there's every one does anyone have any
questions is related to anything we've
discussed so far
if not I'll move on to the next notebook
and some more numpy features yeah you
want a list of variables that sorry
yeah
so I just do a
so in this case now a NBA memory you
want a Python list of a and B right okay
yeah okay so given all so you're saying
if I know B I want to basically have a
function that tells me everything that
shares memory would be oh I don't know
an umpire function to do that I don't
know a Python function to do that I'm
not sure whether you can do that or not
but I mean I'm happy to try it out later
and then if I find a way to do it then
I'm happy to share that with you
currently I don't know how to do that
yeah sorry anyone else yeah yeah sorry
oh okay okay okay so okay so now here
yeah so I burn in brackets now this is
our resulting area where you add the two
areas together and now over here we can
enter now the logic to enter the first
and last get the first and last element
of every row right snow why don't you
tell me so I put the comma here snow
from the left side of the comma I would
specify the logic I want for the rows
right so now what should I put over here
: : - okay and
what what is in the list - one
oh I changer
yeah
Oh
what is the equivalent to
is this what you're expecting
I'll print out the dimensions
so the shape of a is originally 5 comma
5 and B is 5 comma 5 comma 3 it's the
first thing we need to do for these two
to be broadcast able is 1 make both of
them 3-dimensional and now so the third
dimension of a should either be 3 or 1
right and now obviously we can't
artificially introduced it to 3 so using
the NP dot new axis or a reshape you
would make that third dimension 1 now
the 2 can be added together now in the
resulting array C has a shape 5 comma 5
comma 1 yeah 3 5 comma 5 comma 3 yeah
then now when you take this 5 comma 5
comma 3 array you take every alternate
row right and then the first and last
column within what you've selected so
now for the first dimension you say give
me everything and then the next
dimension if you take the last 2
dimension to be the row and column that
I'm talking about or you can choose to
have the first or dimension of the row
and column that I'm talking whichever
one so for this case now let's say out
of my three dimensions I'm saying the
second dimension is rows and the third
dimension is column now give me every
alternate row so on the second dimension
give me every alternate one which is
colon colon 2 so start end skipping two
in between on the last dimension I want
just the first in the last right but in
this case it's 3 so saying alternate is
the same or I could do
yeah 0 & 2 oh it's for sure whoa ok so I
have half an hour left right good ok so
if anyone has any other questions we can
just take it offline actually I wanted
to go through this other notebook first
one went longer than I expected to so
Universal functions stride tricks and
Einstein summation are three really cool
features in numpy and so I'm going to
quickly go through the universal
functions and then move on to stride
tricks and if we have time I in some in
some is really cool so if we don't get
time to do it I'm super happy to you
know talk to you guys about it
afterwards because I just think I need
some is really cool so here we have an
example of creating numpy lists using
arrange function or actually doing it
using a Python list so here using numpy
dot arrange I can create a
hundred-thousand list array in 1.0 4
milliseconds and if I did the same thing
using Python it would take me 5.2
milliseconds so this is just a highlight
while how numpy functions are just
inherently faster than doing things the
pythonic way you got the same thing same
thing for some if I want to sum up all
the elements in my numpy array I could
use the universal function in P dot sum
it takes 462 microseconds to do that now
as I said before loops are not your
friend and here I will show you why or
if I did the same thing if I want to sum
up this 100,000 element array using a
for loop it takes 19 milliseconds to do
that's an entire order of magnitude
slower then using numpy functions to do
it the same for average you got 443
microseconds and 45 milliseconds if you
wanted to use the ABS function this is
interesting if you take these two cases
over here
take these two functions over here if I
just use pythons ABS on a normal integer
versus numpy ABS on a certain on integer
on a float Python ABS as an umpire ABS
the Python abs is faster now if I take
the Python abs and do it on a list of
this size so that's 500 elements versus
numpy abs on the same exact list what do
you think would be faster Python numpy
okay
Python is faster now this example take a
Python array and then using a pythonic
way use or not using Python anyway using
the Python apps function create a new
array of absolutes or use NPR abs on
this array which one do you think will
be first an umpire python okay and yeah
numpy is faster it's twenty six point
nine microseconds and doing in python is
153 microseconds so the numpy dot abs
function works better on numpy arrays
not on any array in general now okay now
I'm excited now this is my favorite
stride tricks you just want to get
through the previous stuff with stride
tricks it's really it's a really neat
way to do things like you know create a
sliding window out of an array and just
to know more complex indexing now I'm
sure I don't have many of you had to
create sliding windows or similar things
and I really what you do is you if
you're doing it in like C or C++ or
something or just pure Python you would
use loops and a whole bunch of other
stuff to get appropriate sliding windows
what you can do with numpy is you can
create strides which essentially will
return a reference to your array and it
will stride through it in whichever way
you need to return whatever sort of
sliding window type function you want so
in this case first I'll show you the
okay so now let's say for this array of
numbers from zero to nine I want a
window
of size 4 and I want to jump by two
elements each time so that means I'd
want my output to be 0 1 2 3 2 3 4 5 4 5
6 7 and 6 7 8 9 so how on Windows of 4
and jumps of 2 now in this one line
function I can do that and this is hot
this is half of it so the first thing to
do with stri tricks is you basically
stride it with a window with a step of 1
at each time so now you first define the
window so here I've got my window taken
care of I've divided my array into
windows of 4 0 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 4 5 6 7 and
whatever and now I want my stride to be
2 so on every alternate one so then
using the colon colon s I can get every
alternate one out of that and then I'm
left with 0 2 0 1 2 3 4 2 3 4 5 4 5 6 7
& 6 7 8 9 so here in one line you are
able to stride over your numpy array in
and get this result and what's awesome
all this is it's super fast and this is
not returning or creating any new memory
this is purely purely done in reference
there is no new memory created over here
and this is how a numpy array is stored
in memory it's essentially us it's a see
structure it's got a pointer to the data
that the area is representing it has a
descriptor of the data it knows how many
dimensions the array has it knows how to
stride over the array and it has a base
it has flags and it has a reference list
so now if you were to so for example if
you looked at this array X that I just
created an a range of 10 and you looked
at the area interface you would see that
this is the pointer to the data that the
array is representing
now if I do stri tricks over that to get
this sort of this new area which is 0 1
1 2 3 4 and I check out what the area
interface is I see the exact same yeah
so you have the exact same memory being
pointed to by both x and y despite me
having done this try tricks so it just
in memory alters the strides so here you
can see the strides are none and the
shape is 10 here the shape is 9 comma 2
and the strides are 8 by 8 so it's just
changed these descriptors around how
memory how python is reading these
arrays out of memory so that it's read
in this new shape so what strides is
doing is if you see in oops this case
over here strides is 8 comma 8 so what
it's telling you is my new resultant
array has a shape of 9 comma 2 on the
first dimension which is 9 my stride is
8 so if you look at this the first row
of this area is 0 comma 1 and the second
row is 1 comma 0 so now when you go from
the first element of the first row to
the first element of the second row so
you've moved 1 a long dimension 1 right
so from 0 1 in memory how much have you
strided you've started one byte or so
you started you have 1 1 byte or 8 bytes
sorry and that's because in the original
array X between 0 & 1 its 1 float offset
right you go 1 float from 0 and you
reach 1 so in memory is linearly laid
out so that descriptor is just telling
you or just telling Python how to read
from memory into this array so that it's
able to do it such that I receive now a
two-dimensional array with 9 rows and 2
columns and it's 0
one two three four and so on and on the
second dimension the stride is also
eight and that's because if you go along
if you go one element over the second
dimension you're going from zero to one
and again as we see over here to go from
zero to one it's one jump so which is
why it's eight so eight in this case is
the size of float and that depends on
the system you're using it could be four
it could be eight and then now when you
go one more on the first dimension you
go from one to two again that's an eight
by jump again you can see over here one
two two is an 8-byte jump so numpy dots
stri tricks is giving you this
functionality of creating complex arrays
like this from a simple base array but
doing it with the speed of something
like a reshape or the something like a
transpose because it's actually not
manipulating data is not creating a new
area it's not copying data anywhere it's
just changing those two fields is just
changing shape and it's just changing
strides in the in the C structure
representing that array
so when python reads this array and it
sees that c structure it knows how to
stride over this piece of memory so that
you're able to see the area or that you
get a view of the array the way you want
it to so it's just changing the
underlying structure which is why using
a function like stride tricks is a lot
faster a lot more efficient than
actually creating a new array by looping
or by whatever other methodology you
would want to use yeah
yes try tricks is a it's an umpire
library function that you can use this
is the syntax now Empire or Lib dot stri
tricks so it's exposed to you you can
use it yeah so everyone understood our
stride tricks because otherwise I can
either go into that into a little more
detail with another example or I can
briefly touch upon instance summation so
whatever you prefer anyone wanna go into
a little more detail on stri tricks or
everyone wants to do Einstein summation
okay so another cool thing in numpy is
ein sum and ein sum in a lot of cases is
really useful because it's faster than
doing stuff in normal numpy in Python in
a few cases for example like the dot
product numpy is just like heavily
optimized the dot product is like
optimization on steroids so nothing's
gonna be that but that's one of those
few functions that are really written
down core in glass or Fortran so they're
really fast but for a lot of other
functions using eine some is faster than
using a normal numpy function so here
the syntax is a little tricky so for
example if I have these two arrays a and
B so now both of these are two
dimensional arrays of size 3 comma 3
now with n some you have two arguments
that you two or more arguments that you
pass to it the first argument is a
string and the string is what defines
the function that it that should take
place now with this Einstein summation
so the the syntax you would use is like
this so you have this arrow operator on
the left hand side of the arrow operator
you define the dimensions of the input
on the right-hand side of the operator
of the arrow operator you define the
dimensions
of the output so here in this case I'm
passing in the array a to it a has two
dimensions and convention is you start
with the first dimension being named as
a and then you go ijk so on doesn't have
to be is just convention so now here
I've said my input array has two
dimensions the first dimension is I the
second dimension is labeled as J there's
only one so there's nothing else on the
left-hand side of the arrow on the
right-hand side I've left it blank when
you leave it blank in this case it
simply translates to the applies the to
replicate the input on the output side
and what this does is just returns the
entire matrix as it is which is the same
as doing a dot view or a of : or the
same thing so this isn't really a cool
example of I on some this is just to
show you that on the left hand side you
have the inputs on the right hand side
you have the output now what you can do
over here is say okay fine my inputs are
IJ my inputs are these two dimensions
but on my output I want only one
dimension and here it returns three six
and 15 so when I leave a dimension out
of the output it tells me that I want to
sum along that dimension so here my
input is I comma J so that's dimension
zero dimension 1 my output is just I so
as dimension 0 I've left out dimension 1
so it tells me OK for the input array
that has two dimensions my output array
should have only one dimension and it
should be summed along dimension 0 so
leaving out something on the right-hand
side of mine some indicates summation to
happen along that dimension so in this
case when I've done i comma j IJ on the
left hand side and just I on the right
side it sums it along the dimension J
which is axis 1 which is why the
resultant array is 3 6 and 15
now if you were to do the same thing in
this case I say my input is IJ and my
output should be J I it is me telling I
in some that I want the transpose so my
input has a dimension I NJ my output
also has two dimensions but the first is
J and the second is I so it's taking the
dimension is taking inj from the left
hand side which is the input and
reversing them and giving me the output
so it's doing a transpose of my matrix
using this Einstein Einstein notation
now as I showed you that extremely
elegant way earlier to get the diagonal
of a matrix using the two lists as rows
and columns you can do the same thing
using Einstein's summation so here my
left hand side is just I and I so now I
know it's two dimensions because I
passed in two characters on the left
hand side but I've labeled both of them
as I so I'm saying on my input
I want the two dimensions where I want
equality between the two dimensions so
and on the right hand side I only want
to see one value so on my right hand
side to be one dimensional and here it
returns the diagonals of the matrix
which is the same as using numpy dot
diag but you can see here this is one of
the cases where Einstein Einstein
summation is faster than using a normal
number function and all of these cases
are great when the examples are small
but the true power comes in when you use
much larger areas then you're actually
able to see noticeable differences in
times taken using normal numpy functions
and using functions like what I've shown
you here with the eye on some you can do
the same thing with the trace of the
matrix so here on the right hand side of
this case I've said give me back one
dime
sumit you have said give me back one
dimension which is why I've received
this 1 comma 2 comma 5 here this is the
same as doing this which is saying on my
input I have two dimensions and on my
right output I have nothing so summit
along that which is why the 1 comma 2
comma 5 is summed to give me it so
anytime you exclude something on the
right-hand side you are saying some
along the dimension that you just
excluded which is why you're able to get
the trace of the matrix in this way so
now here this is an example of using
Einstein's summation for matrix
multiplication and this is where you'll
really understand the syntax in more
detail so here I have my two matrices a
and B this is the matrix multiplication
of the two now when I use Einsteins an
Einstein summation node notation to
represent this I now on the left hand
side of the arrow need to pass in the
dimensions for both theories because I'm
passing to Irish to this function so I'm
saying my first array is defined by with
the dimensions I comma J my second is
defined by again I comma J and my output
should be I comma J so what this does is
anytime you have the same variables or
the same letter used to denote
dimensions of a matrix on the left-hand
side you are telling Einstein summation
to multiply those dimensions together so
here I have I and J for array a I have I
and J for Arabi as well now both I and J
are repeated and they used to represent
both these areas so what you're telling
I on some is multiply the two together
because dimension 1 is I in a dimension
1 is i in g NB i mentioned 2 is j in a
dimension 2 is J in B now because I've
repeated the notice of the notation I've
used it is it me
enzymes well I'm indicating to iron some
that I want multiplication to happen
along those two and my output is again I
J which means I don't any summation to
happen so just return everything as it
is and it multiplies element by element
each element from a and each element of
B and returns that I read to me element
wise multiplication yeah
and now traditional matrix
multiplication is shown over here so now
in matrix multiplication you multiply
the rows of the first matrix with the
columns of the second Matrix right and
then you add that together and that
becomes the element or the output at
that particular location and you do that
for the whole array so now for array a
I've called it I comma J so my rows are
I and my columns are J for array B I've
called my rows as J and my row wise as J
and column wise as K so now the columns
of a which means if you go from left to
right on a and if you go from top to
bottom on B are both represented by the
same letter J in this case which means
you want multiplication to happen
between those two dimensions and on my
output I've left out J which means I
want addition to happen along that
dimension as well and I want the other
two dimensions to be what the shape of
my output is so you know when you have
matrix multiplication you have the rows
and columns the columns of the first and
the rows of the second should be equal
and the output is the rows of the first
and the columns of the second right so
here you have I comma J and J comma K as
what's defining the dimensions of the
input so here you have the columns of
the first and the rows of the second as
equal because both are J and the output
dimensions are I and K which is the rows
of the first and the columns of the
second and then when you run this and
you multiply it you see that you get the
matrix or you have the traditional
matrix multiplication of these two
elements so in having something in
on the left indicates multiplication
between these two and excluding
something on the right means addition
along that axis and just to give you an
indication of how fast this is
so here the numpy dot function is faster
and that's because dot is written in
thing is written in blas so dot is one
of those functions that you will not
find you will I do not think you will
find any other function in numpy to
replace dot that will be faster than dot
yeah so that's using I in some and now
this example over here do I have how
much time do I have left okay so I think
I can quickly go through this example so
this is an example that does convolution
of two matrices using straight tricks
and I on some it does everyone know what
convolution is this give sort of shows
how convolution works so the lower
matrix the larger one is for example
matrix a and the smaller matrix on top
which is this one over here is called
the kernel so what you do with
convolution is you take the kernel and
you multiply each subsection of the
larger array with that kernel and then
you can apply any function you want what
you can add all of them together and
have that as your output and you slide
that kernel along the larger original
matrix to retrieve whatever output you
want and that process is called
convolution now to do that using numpy I
take the first I create the larger
matrix a which is 0 to 24 in the shape 5
comma 5 I create a filter or my kernel
of shape 3 comma 3 and these are the
values I've given it now I want to
multiply this 3 by 3 kernel over all 3
by 3 sub matrices from my larger 5 by 5
matrix
now how would you do that if you can't
loop you would either and you would
probably need to create all of those
three by three sub matrices multiply the
larger matrix with it and then add them
together so you get your final output
what you can do using stri tricks is
create a reference to that larger matrix
that strides over it such that the
resulting shape is all of those sub
matrix sub 3x3 matrices and then you
multiply the kernel over each of them so
here what I've done is I've defined so
now if you take a five by five array and
you want to multiply three by three
matrices over each of them you would
have one like this two three you would
have three multiple three sub matrices
at prices along each column you would
have three sub matrices along each row
each of those sub matrices will have
three rows and three columns so the
final resultant ad array of sub arrays
that you should get from stri tricks
would be of dimension three by three by
three by three so that's what I've
created over here just define the shape
and define the strides that I need to
take so the shape is three by three by
three by three and the strides I've
defined is forty by eight forty by eight
and I'll explain why so here if you look
at the sub matrices these are the sub
matrices that have been created so you
look at the original now the first sub
matrix is 0 1 2 5 6 7 10 11 12 then 1 2
3 6 7 8 11 12 13 and so on now the first
dimension of Strides was 40 now you look
at the first element over here which is
0 or let's print that out
okay now this is the first element of
the this is basely element zero zero
zero zero now if I want to check what
the stride should be a long dimension
one let me look at what value is there
what value would I get if I move by one
dimension along the first dimension by
one value along the first dimension and
that is five now in my original matrix
from zero to five how many jumps are
there I go one two three four and five I
have to jump five times on my original
array to get the first jump of the first
dimension of my resultant sub matrix
area right so now five jumps of floats
in this case is a stride of 40 which is
why the first element over here is 40
now if I want to find what the strides
of my second dimension should be let me
see what value I get again this is zero
and if I move by one along Diamond the
second dimension I get one now if you
look at the first the original array to
go from zero to one the jump is eight
which is why the strides on the second
dimension is eight now I do the same
thing for the third it's zero and if I
go by jump by one it's five again which
means now the stride along the third
dimension is again forty and again zero
to 1 its 1 so the stride along the last
dimension is 8 which is why the
resultant strides are 48 48 and now I
create those sub matrices I've created
those sub matrices already and these are
the sub matrices and now I need to
multiply my each of these sub matrices
which are convolution filters sorry I
need to multiply the convolution filter
with each of these sub matrices and then
sum them up together so each 3 by 3
matrix is multiplied with the 3 by 3
filter
multiplied together summed up to give
one value and that is the value that is
in my final output so to do that I use
this Einstein summation so on my first
array the conf filter it's
two-dimensional so I define the
dimensions as I and J the second array
the sub matrices are four-dimensional
right it's three by three by three by
three so I call those ijkl now here I
and J are common between cons filter and
sub matrices that means I want the
entire cone filter matrix to be
multiplied with the first two dimensions
of the sub matrices which means each 3
by 3 matrix will be multiplied with the
convolution filter
I've excluded I and J from the output
which means I and J should be summed up
which is essentially taking the 3 by 3
cone filter the 3 by 3 sub matrix
multiplying it together adding up all
the elements into it and then my final
output should only have the dimensions
KNL which is in this case 3 by 3 but the
first two dimensions are being
multiplied with each other and it tells
me that I have no time left so I'll end
with this and you can see the output
over here and this is the result in
output you get I understand that I had
to hurry up through the last bits the
first notebook took a little longer than
expected
but I am more than happy to talk to you
in more detail about n some stray tricks
you funks or any of the other stuff I've
talked about because these are all
really cool functions and things I
really use a lot and I think would be
very beneficial if you use them as well
so more than happy to talk to you about
that offline other than that thank you I
hoped you liked whatever I spoke about
and I hope you found some of this at
least useful and we'll use this in your
work later on Thanks
[Applause]